welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm grace Helbig your host guess
what guys exciting episode ahead you
have been trigger warned we have Clayton
James aka a kid but from sugar pine 7
with us who's here today we've only had
Stephens septic on last time he said
some disparaging things about kid that
we really wanted to get to the bottom of
today plus he's just a real nice boy
with real genuine thoughts and feelings
and opinions about starting a goddamn
cool business with his cool friends so
let's jump into that on this episode of
not too deep with kid this episode of
not too deep is brought to you by drop
if you spend with brands like uber
Starbucks Trader Joe's and Sephora then
you're missing out on free cash rewards
with the drop app for a limited time if
you head to the App Store or Google Play
and sign up for the drop app using the
code grace you'll receive a $10
Starbucks gift card right away make sure
to link a debit or credit card to the
app when you sign up to claim your
reward
[Music]
Clayton akin James what's up it's here
with us yeah Steven here he talked very
negatively about all of you amazing take
us through how did you guys meet each
other
Steve and I met way back in the day I
want to say like 2012 or 2013 and then
from a youtube like influencer manager
who was trying to start like a group of
youtubers back when we did gaming and he
just brought us together and we just
instantly hit it off and there's like a
bunch of us in there but he and I really
clicked and then we just kind of stayed
in touch ever since and collaborated and
became best friends really yeah and then
I like moved in with him in 2015 yeah
what's it like in this country its
frigid cold yeah um it's way better I
just love it
I love Canada it's home but it's LA you
know two years so it's still so fresh
exactly it's a little fresh you don't
have that I realized that the first
eight months that you're here is when
you feel like ah I made it yeah this is
it yeah like you look at the mountains
and it like gives you butterflies yeah
and then we lose it and now it's like
you get jaded
and like everyone sucks and then one
sucks they do first eight months you
learn that you're like oh it's great
yeah bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and
you trust everyone and then your trust
gets broken just enough the how did
sugar pine come to be how did this whole
collaborative thing happen
it all started way back yeah and the day
as well when SourceFed shut down I'm
sure you're familiar with SourceFed yeah
we just had Lee and Steven oh great
before you even leave my baby so when
that shut down Steve was like well I saw
Steve work justify his channel and he
worked there too yeah he was the host
there in the right at the end of it when
it all died and it seems to be a
reoccurring thing man yeah no but uh he
he kept his channel going and he's like
well you know what what am I gonna do
next I got to do something so he came
over to my place just because he's like
well kids in LA for a couple months yeah
and just vlog and I just immediately
jumped into character cuz he and I have
this like dynamic that for the longest
time we couldn't find anybody else who
had that like got each other in that
bidding way or you can always know when
when you're bidding like right just
clicked well so we filmed and it was
super funny to us anyways and then all
the audience from SourceFed that needed
somewhere to go went to Steve's channel
and luckily we made this funny content
back in the day that they really
resonated with people we just kept doing
it and then time went by you know and we
had James well he had Steve had James
film for him because he also worked at
SourceFed okay and then James became one
of our best friends we all just started
making videos you know then it just kind
of took off from there
yeah how did you develop your character
kid because I'm sure lot of people when
I first saw I got introduced to you guys
you guys won a Streamy award for best
show I think you beat don't fill the
frame we don't deserve a oh we're so
great you guys young and fun these guys
tunes and then I went on YouTube after
and I like binge - so many episodes I
was like cool so cool to me and it's
like I got mad at it because I was like
why didn't I think about this why didn't
I do what they're doing yeah exactly
like
innovative vlogs pissing me off but
kudos to them it was cool to find out
that you even watched like oh you we
didn't know that anyone gave a [ __ ] like
we just thought oh we just have the
SourceFed audience and that's why we're
getting views which was amazing really
cool we can do this yeah
but then when we found out that like
there was other creators that and just
like cool people like finding out that
the value flowed like duh yeah you like
there's all these other cool creators
that are so much more talented than we
are doing something so cool it was
getting so at least for me like the
platform is so repetitive and no
everyone was doing the same like let's
do a makeup tutorial it's still make
slime let's all do the challenge and
things like that
my poser slime ten million views from
the kids channel how did you come up
with your character people probably when
I first saw I didn't realize that you
were in character that was amazing
before let me just touch on once again
really quick because it was I wish we
could go back to this time like when
people thought that a lot of it was real
because it's it's amazing now to think
that oh my god people thought it was
real yeah it looked like it was
ridiculous guys how the [ __ ] can I swear
on this of course how the [ __ ] did you
think that it was real but back then it
was kind of frustrating it was like
almost offensive that people thought I
was this this crazy character I was like
obviously it's fake guys like no one
does that but no I wish I could go back
to that but how did I come up with the
character I just kind of I've always
been a goofy boy I think and my
influences have always been like Jim
Carrey Williams and all these amazing
legends and that's just kind of also
been Who I am so when I'm performing for
people aren't trying to entertain I just
naturally go to a goofy place yeah and
then it's very silly yeah exactly and
the bro voice was just kind of the
accent and the type of character that I
use as a vehicle to be a goofy person
which I did before we started filming
with my roommate at the time John cryos
this house bug got real interested in oh
I'm Canadian
they're like there's an immigrant in the
house okay bust me this is wired this
whole time I didn't want to tell you
this dude I'm a green card I thought was
at least [ __ ] man
but anyway so I got the voice by goofing
around with my friend who kind of
naturally talked like that on crayons
gaming he's like he's blew up now he's a
big gamer but he would always like talk
like a bra and he black oh that was
[ __ ] hilarious so like when your
friend does something funny and you just
start doing it with yeah you mean like
it's like your thing with him and then I
start doing that with him constantly and
he was vaping and then I would
eventually take hits of his vape and I I
was just like oh this is hilarious like
so stupid hilarious and I used it as
something like a prop in the videos and
then I actually started vaping and then
oh yeah yeah when I he's a whole other
story but with you guys yeah I was like
I can if this is a bit but they all vape
they're really committed to this [ __ ]
bit right now because it was a little
bit like we're in a fog machine all day
I wouldn't have any part machines just
vaping on the side for the dance
sequence night fog correct me if I'm
wrong or if you remember or not but I
think we actually had times we were like
okay do a big hit of vapor here and just
wofe it around and added to the fog
machine that would look very stylized
crazy yeah yeah that's where all that
came from and then the vaping just
started from John as well because yeah
John ruined a lot of people and blame it
on to him so many people started vaping
from from your show the odd times
someone will say you know what I quit
smoking and started vaping because of
you guys but there are like I guess I
feel good about that but there's far
more people who started vaping from
nothing from us is so funny yeah I'm
pretty proud that we're giving kids um
you know lung disease and stuff like
that you're super committed you know
it's kind of like being on undercover
villain you really are putting lots of
people yeah I had a man Reno when we
first start making videos I mean Hannah
does my drunk kitchen maybe does a
drinking video we would do a lot of
getting drunk
young kids that are like oh I took my
first job or they tell us that we're
like I don't know this is the best
behavior to be like supporting I'm gonna
get drunk and make a Stouffer's mac and
cheese exactly so but I mean the the
engagement is there people are excited
about it yeah it's um it's gone down
like anything like I think one of our
downfalls was actually how how fast
things grew because then oh yeah you
know when you blow up you inevitably go
down yeah sounds like a roller coaster
sorana like Arlo with a slight upward
trend right now I'm just trying to like
figure it out but it's also a harder
space because how long have you been
doing this on two years yeah so I feel
like that's the natural time that you
start to plateau or like people grow out
of your content totally yes this just
keeps growing it's so concentrated so
getting people to find you for the first
time is so much harder than it used to
be and trends recycle like we just gonna
start making slime videos or something
try it out how do you guys come up with
the narrative so where people don't know
it is a scripted ish narrative
improvised narrative mm-hmm so how does
that happen you guys have like literal
story board meetings yeah all the time
every single day even today but like it
like the first few seasons we're in like
what we call our like fifth season I
think or an extended fourth season but
it's um it used to be a lot more
scripted yeah where we would come up
with a storyline and sometimes we would
write even like dialogue and stuff like
that but now it's gotten to a point
where we realized people would rather
see us just go have fun and play and
then we'll talk about like that
underlying storyline beforehand like
okay so Steve's gonna do this and he's
gonna lie about that and then we'll go
to here so they're kind of like cues to
hit throughout it and then we just
improv all between it because we just
love improv a you make each other laugh
yeah you guys are on it's really great
to watch because it's literally like
such guerilla style it is yeah that's
fun so you don't like behold into one
specific script yeah it can get crazy
when you don't know what to do or you
don't have the you're too far gone to
the improv side we're like what are we
going to do with the improv and
sometimes will accidentally make a video
that just ends up being kind of like
nothing like there was no point to it
other than goofing around but also
that's kind of like the essence of
YouTube so it's nice
and clan like just something that is
entertaining and doesn't really have any
purpose totally have there been any
episodes that went too far that didn't
see the light of day
maybe not full videos but I know there
have been bits all the time that have to
cut out like today I made a MeetMe to
joke that not at me to joke but James
kissed me on the mouth and walked away
and I was just like I just got me too
and that I I don't know if it's gonna
make it I was like do you think like
should we even put that in yeah everyone
I don't even know if it's gonna be in it
now but she's like you're fine he's like
no no no it's funny like the context is
good yeah I think but you know we're in
a place now where people are comfortable
being offended by things now which like
so comfortable the the entertainer and
me goes like come on man yeah chill the
[ __ ] out yeah you have to be a laugh at
everything but then I'm learning as I'm
getting older that like people do get
hurt by things and just because you know
a lot of people can laugh at something
and it's just a tough so we're balanced
it's a hard day
it's especially when you do comedy that
you're like but I want this to me is
funny but you then you have to respect
that like it might not be funny to
someone else or something and it's so
hard to rationalize like that that is
something you need to respect instead of
like no you're taking my joke away from
me I know you don't want to hurt people
but at the same time like the comedian
in me makes me want to just like laugh
at everything totally it's like that
it's so much more enjoyable even your
own like since you're insecure about
like and I'll even get offended
sometimes if somebody makes fun or
something about me that like I just
happen to be more emotional that day or
yeah ever but that doesn't mean I want
to like shut everything down forever I
mean like things have to be joked about
yeah it brings lightness to it lemon dee
take the weight out of this right yeah
for instance today you got kissed you
guys don't seem to have like is there a
safe word is there something like you I
wish there was a safe word man no I'm
probably the one who has the least
boundaries I think but I don't know I
think we're all on the same pit we're so
on the same page that you know
anything's game yeah for the most part
and then I know we'll
like there's still touchy things about
people and you know that like sometimes
you're in that bit mode where you're
gonna say something that's gonna again
offend or something but sometimes you do
it anyways and hope that they just get
it and you're on the same page but
sometimes you know but for the most part
yeah we're on the same page so the
boundaries generally aren't there how do
you push Steve's buttons
what are his buttons teach us his
triggers that's job steve is a
complicated soul he uh he doesn't really
get offended by a whole lot I think but
they seem pretty owners here he's just
like a workaholic it sounds like he's a
workaholic you know and I think that
like he'll get frustrated if maybe he's
if you're arguing with him if like he
believes one thing and you believe
something else and whether I mean
everyone gets frustrated but that's
where he'll I noticed his buttons are
pushed most of all or someone's not if
you're if he's bidding about something
that maybe is hurting someone's feelings
and they're not having it yeah that'll
piss him off cuz he'd be like come on
man this is what we're doing this is why
we're here which I understand both sides
of you know totally and you guys also
have your podcast now mm-hmm is that you
guys as you it's kind of just whatever I
mean we're not going in there like with
masks on right we're just kind of you're
not going in there in full character
yeah we just bit like I pretty much just
M me on the podcast but like Oh a bit or
I'll go into character for a moment to
tell you know engage in a bit or
something but people know that it's just
like us talking but we also it's a
comedy entertainment podcast okay using
air quotes yeah you know but yeah we go
in there like knowing that maybe we're
embellishing our thoughts on something
cuz I don't care about a whole lot you
know like controversial topics going on
like I mean I can have an opinion but
like an opinion isn't enough to talk
about for 10 minute she's like yeah I
think this person's a monster but no you
have to like yeah yeah yeah entertain
your audience have to talk about it so
you have to you know grow it make you
embellish your opinion a bit we'll do
that even if you know it's an extreme
version of what we actually feel for the
podcast because it's entertaining
otherwise it's like okay how serious you
guys get on there do you get deep it can
be yeah we've got pretty deep I think
the last podcast or maybe two podcasts
ago James Steve got into an argument
about
you know bidding when it's hurting
someone's feelings and someone and
Steve's like pushing it and pushing it
and then he got pissed that James wasn't
you know like going into it but we
posted it it was like 20 minutes of some
serious conversation but we always yeah
brothers some brothers fight and
sometimes it's cool to show that side
you know yeah I think that's really
interesting especially because you guys
are so on all the time that when you
take down the wall it's a little bit and
let people like listen and find out who
you guys are and how you interact plus
is just nice to watch how like an we
talked about this a little bit with
valley folk because they're all friends
that work together like where they draw
the line and how to sometimes it's
really nice to see how adult especially
men can disagree and then like rectify
or reconcile yeah afterwards and like
that's a good example
exactly yeah like even on the podcast
like we've argued before but we always
come together and go like guys we love
each other you know and make up even not
for the cameras like yeah ever been like
everything's great cameras off yeah
[ __ ] hate you we usually try to
figure it out but speaking of the valley
folk too like I'm just thinking about my
perspective of like they're honest as
well like I never see the struggle of
their of them unless maybe you're just
you hear like oh yeah we're having a
tough week for them yeah yeah generally
they're they're on to like they see it
together yeah and they just really were
just talking with Lee and Steve about it
that they just really like you guys
support each other and respect each
other even if they have disagreements
they like walk it off and they know it's
not coming from a bad place yeah yes you
never see them really argue or fight or
anything no no I guess sometimes little
bits here and there people you know
human condition okay so this I asked
them this I'm curious about your
perspective what's it like been because
you guys basically started a business
together yeah and your friends so how's
that been that's gotta be a huge
learning curve yeah I mean the funny
thing is like Steve started it as like a
business in which kid he was the boss
for the first like year of it I mean
still kind of like our number one guy
because like to show supposed to be
about him which right you know but he
started it and he was like the boss and
he was paying us like out of his pocket
with us for a while and then sold the
company to a roosterteeth and then we
all got employed by rooster teeth's and
it's been like
the learning curve was joining
roosterteeth because that's when we were
forced to be business people right you
know before it was just like friends
hanging out and getting paid because
like I'm giving you all my time for this
YouTube channel right which is like ours
but it's yours
yeah and that was just like fun but also
you know it wasn't making a ton of money
but sure
so like that part wasn't hard but I
think it puts it puts friendships in
difficult positions for sure I would say
like I love them so much but like when
you work with your friends every day it
gets hard and you you're not like you
hang it you just do together all the
time so you butt heads more you mean
naturally like if you hang out with
people too often like it's like that but
I love them to death ya know it is
interesting too
because you guys have you want to
maintain your friendships but you have
to look at what hat you're wearing and
what time like are we businessmen right
now working together are we friends that
love each other and you have to be able
to like kind of separate the two exactly
and understand like oh you're not coming
for me as a friend you're coming for me
from a business point of view and I have
to rectify that yeah and especially
because we never really separated it in
the beginning before it was like we're
all just friend for the for the like
majority of the peak of the success of
it we were just all friends it wasn't
really a business thing so now that it's
a business thing it feels like you know
we're not the peak anymore so it almost
feels like we're doing things wrong even
though we know we're supposed to be
doing it from more of a business
standpoint so it's like conflicting as
far as like well you know it was better
when we were doing it as friends we
weren't in this business boat but it has
to be like this yeah yeah business
YouTube business know you guys started
the same way I think we all started
which is just like I genuinely enjoy
making these videos with my friends and
like if we get paid cool but that's a
byproduct of just having fish exactly
and then you have to go oh no but now
this is my job and I need to consider it
my job and it takes some of the fun away
and then when you ya lose numbers or
subscribers or whatever then you're like
what am I doing wrong
oh so in my head a little bit too much
about the business side of things that
I'm not enjoying it as much as actually
being on a production schedule to like
it's just like yeah what's your
production schedule like because you
guys churn out content mmm so we're
filming six videos a week yeah and a
podcast I think so it's just like it's a
lot like even in the peak of it when it
was like not as stressful
because we were you know filming with it
the inspiration hits and that's when
it's best to film but when you need to
force inspiration it's a little harder
but like I'm learning from the great
people at fun house that and like Bruce
has been like just really good with like
understanding that you you yeah you can
push it and you can get it out and you
can decide to enjoy it and not be bummed
out or not bummed out but like burnt out
yeah you can push past the burn out and
just be like you just gotta enjoy it
just kind of like force yourself to
actually enjoy it so change your mindset
and enjoy it enjoy what that ideal even
if you're not a big fan of is like just
enjoy it
you got a great life coach go she's our
boss Center and her life coach yeah is
this a self-imposed production schedule
like did you guys decide on six episodes
a week know that we have to do we have
like that deadline but we're in the
office nine to six every single day damn
well five days a week like like normal
people yeah yeah I mean I'm sure if we
we could choose to do things a little
differently but that just seems like if
we're doing that then we'll be on the
right track where is it we don't want to
like slack in any way yeah it doesn't
give you time to overanalyze anything
cuz you have to turn out content so it's
just literally improving saying yes to
ideas and like making [ __ ] exactly I
used to be that way to be so young it's
all I got left
Clayton I love podcast me to know
they're super fun okay speaking of the
things that podcast do we're gonna take
a quick break and when we get back we
have more questions for clay again a kid
that's both of my name's
[Laughter]
[Music]
to support for today's show comes from
coca topia after a long day it's nice to
unwind and enjoy some me time and what
better way to do that than with a
delicious dark chocolate truffle from
coca topia it is creamy chocolatey
delicious and now you can indulge in
delicious chocolate without the
sacrifice on calories because the dark
chocolate truffle is only 40 calories
you heard me that's 45 percent fewer
calories then lint plus it has less fat
and less sugar too it's the perfect
treat after a meal during a girl's
weekend gathering or paired with a glass
of wine ready to try for yourself visit
coca topia calm and enter the promo code
grace at checkout to get 50% off your
first order make sure you type the code
in all caps that si o si o top-8 calm
and enter promo code grac e at checkout
to get 50% off your first order indulge
without the guilt this episode not too
deep is brought you by brew mate
whatever your taste in beer wine or
spirits brew mate make sure every sip is
the perfect temp roommate stylish
insulated drink ware is designed to keep
your favorite beverages ice-cold all day
and guys I got a hologram flask from
roommate I'm living my best life I don't
mean to alarm you but I'm living in 3019
because it's got a bejeweled top to it
and yes it does keep my Tito's very very
cold I can't I can't believe it you know
I'm 33 and thriving and I'm sorry that
you guys haven't gotten on my level but
you can don't settle for warm alcohol
chill out with your favorite drinks all
day long with brew mate visit brew mate
calm and add code grace to get 15% off
your first order that's 15% off your
first order when you go to be are you ma
te comm and add code grace where's the
music side come from because that's when
you guys retail you're like will you be
in this music videos like you really
make music yeah I remember so yeah I
remember you were in that right yeah but
for me musics just bending my life for
ever and Steve I think it's been in him
forever but he's explored it throughout
his YouTube world like he's always kind
of like back in the day tinkering and
make it he made like digital music and
then now we're making like you know pop
punk with a little bit of digitally but
yeah we just got always been musicians
yeah you guys creating they get full
album or is it just like songs here and
then doing singles but we're on like
somewhat of a schedule for it we're
trying to release a song like at least
once a month okay and do a music video
for it as well music video but we yeah
we're thinking about doing now but we're
just trying to Cole first just make
stuff and get to the point where we're
like comfortable yeah making music and
we like where we're at with it cuz right
now we're just kind of like getting
better every song great but eventually
that's cool it's also great to diversify
you don't feel like we're holding to
gesturing the same like types of it
boosts your motivation you know when you
do something new totally ok the funny
thing too that I notice about all of you
maybe not James that you're all married
yeah is James married too
no James has a girlfriend who's been
with for a while okay Steve's engaged to
be married soon and I'm married
how was your wedding it was amazing what
it it was December 1st
yeah okay and yeah I love it I love
being married it's like the greatest
thing of all time truly have you always
wanted to be married
yeah oh my god I've always been such a
romantic like as a kid I was like I'll
never find the girl that I can just sit
with and watch Netflix and yeah who gets
my jokes and stuff but like just
randomly found Sammy Jo getting a phone
call and turning it off it's Argo so
should we answer
I sure answer it's Steve I'm sure used
to calling for every Caesar goes oh
you're on Grace's podcast Steve god I
hope this is a butt-dial this is for
sure about that oh yeah yeah talk to her
Steve he was actually definitely calling
cuz I told him that you guys are you
were gonna be here okay
that's so funny how did you meet your
wife
we met through the show actually really
yeah Steve Neuer from I don't know how
he knew her for like a little bit mutual
friend or something and then
we casted her to play my girlfriend on
the show really yeah like my twin my
tinder date oh and then I was like wow I
just need to know this girl she's so
cool
like she got everything she enjoyed it
all she was super beautiful and I wanted
to know her and then I just heard a
messenger yeah and I was like yeah she
was like sure yeah so how long did you
guys date before you got married we were
together for I want to say six months
before being married it was married yet
Wow was the decision serious way yeah
the decision was that we love each other
it was like it wasn't just for the green
card we'd love to show them wanted to be
together forever and the green card
thing was just like it had to happen for
us to be together okay and we wanted to
and we wanted to get married so we did
get married is a great reason to get
married exactly yeah it's been like it's
going on two years of of being together
soon in July sometime sorry babe what
was the first date like it was amazing
it was one of those dates that you're
like oh wow Wow yeah exactly I have to
marry her in six months yeah it was just
unreal like we just did all the classic
romantic things and stayed up till like
2:00 in the morning at Santa Monica Pier
on the beach on one of those lighthouses
that's cute a [ __ ] took her to dinner or
yeah I think it took good to know that
day but on the night I proposed I
reenacted that date and we also met Ed
Sheeran that night at the restaurant I
was like love your music my we've made a
new yet Edie yeah but I can feel it I
can feel it's coming
that's so cool it was a sign if Ed
Sheeran walks in on your night that
you're proposing then you're gonna be
together forever if it's like certain
things do feel like signs like you'll be
like wow solidifying her right now yeah
the guy those romantic songs in our
present day you know culture what did
you guys do for Stephens birthday was
this recent Steve didn't tell anyone
about his birthday this year
really yeah that's someone who's known
him almost the longest I just didn't
know his birthday I don't think he
remembers mine
I just forgot but he hid it from us on
purpose on purpose and we found out at
the end of the day because he got a
phone call from his parents when we're
at like a cafe in Toluca Lake and he's
like oh thanks so much yeah it's been
good I was like my heart sank and I
looked over at James and I was like I
said Steve and he's like I think James
made no emotion to his face he just
looked over at me when I was just really
hoping that it wasn't one of those
moments that were like now you remember
how did you [ __ ] guys forget my
birthday my best friend
forgot my [ __ ] birthday and I always
hope people remember my birthday but
yeah you know so you just hate
celebrating it that's why he knew Cheban
wants every single person in the world
to see it's very conflicting I want
everyone to celebrate my birthday I
don't even know what's like the most
regretful night you guys have had
together regretful night or the best one
sometimes those go hand in hand the best
night hmm
Wow we've had a lot of cool nights I
don't think we've had a regretful night
there's there's there is a regretful
night but I I can't say yet maybe in
like five years we've not done too much
crazy stuff
that's good oh we just had a lot of
great nights like we just wouldn't we
used to party all the time of it great
nights we had great nights recently we
went to the comedy store and that was a
great night
very great nights it was great yeah we
just went to see the stand-ups and
they're just glad you're my neighbors
that was really funny cool and then I
went again the next day but yeah we just
we've a lot of good nights one day when
I'm ready to tell crazy stories
a handful of regretful nights that just
like this will bring up bad feeling if I
had more time to think about it I'm sure
there was ones that I could oh there is
one I could tell it doesn't involve my
does involve Steve that's okay I yeah it
doesn't policy I wish it did there was
this one time I'll just get right down
to it but I went to a a Canadian casino
in Quebec and a woman like very quickly
Bobby drinks brought me to a strip club
and then to her house and my friend was
there with me and I was making love to
her upstairs wasn't love I just didn't
want to be like I was liking her
upstairs and then my friend was
downstairs and he was stealing her
jewelry after being upstairs he came
downstairs and saw him hunched over
looking through her [ __ ] [ __ ] and he
had jewelry and CDs in his hand at this
point I was like doing and he turns
around he's like we gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here did you have sex with her
dude what are you doing you're robbing
her she's getting first twice did you
not do anything and then with my shirt
and most of my clothes off we ran down
the street we ran away and then my
brother grabbed a bottle of her wine
that was there yeah Wow did your friend
have a history of kleptomania no he was
a good dude he was in the most is a good
dude you know I haven't talked to him in
a while but he's a good dude
he's in jail now yeah he's actually
Tana MoBay was crazy that's so nuts well
that does sound like a regretful night
well let's just say it's Steve that was
there yes Steve exactly he loves CDs
turns out yeah CDs that was the other
thing I was like the jewelry as someone
who was gonna steal understandable yeah
the CDs what do you think it's on it man
videos of her showing your credit cards
that's very funny
something desperate about someone
stealing CDs and I'd be like yeah just
take them I love Blue's Clues season
four early 2000s that's absolutely has
Steven ever made you cry for better or
worse hmm I don't think so but maybe
maybe he hurt my feelings I thought
about it at one time but like is he
sentimental he seems a little like I
usually know a lovable robot yeah he's a
robot
yeah he's not but he can get sentimental
you get those moments with him once in a
while like if we're driving around
having a good time both in a good mood
it needs to be like a perfect formula I
thought for us to like you know if
someone's like stressed about work it's
not gonna happen or whatever and same
with me so it's like but if we're on the
right tone and we're just driving around
or something and put a song on there
reminds us of when we live together in
Toluca Lake we'll be like I love you
brother
you're my best friend bro all right
let's go to the car now robots in the
office did you ever participate in
school talent shows because you guys
have this your character participates in
a talent show right
my character participates in the talent
show we've done so many videos I know I
can't trust me when people come up and
they say something to me that no like a
phrase that I'm like from one video that
didn't really do like 2011 I'm like I
bet I'd said that yes
take care now was it shows in real life
yeah yeah I've been some talent shows in
high school I did talent shows and like
musical theater and stuff
yeah and yeah that's about it didn't go
to college so what was your talent
singing it was um yeah no actually the
town shows I performed in I was like a
bass player or a drummer for a band at
the time okay
cuz I just didn't have the confidence to
do solo stuff cool no it was a little
like weird kids long Justin Bieber hair
at the time what are the fan
interactions like for you made people
like on streets yeah yeah really I am
very grateful to meet anyone who
supports us so I'm just always like I'm
always amazed it happens like decently
frequently in LA we go out yeah like all
over the place we do yeah I mean even
just by a Starbucks or something like
two Marines came up to us the other day
literally two days ago Marines yeah
young guys yeah I'm not even making it
up they're like no they were Marines
they were gamers but they came up with
and I'm just like wow it's so nice to
see you guys how this is going on I want
to give them a good interaction right I
don't know if that's like a like a thing
cuz I'm thinking about it like if I even
should be but like I think about [ __ ]
like that where I'm like I'm grateful
and I want to make sure that you get out
of this what you wanted yeah because I
know what it's like to be I'm a fan of
so many people and right when they're
good to me and I go home and I'm like
that was [ __ ] awesome well it makes
me feel so good yeah you want to believe
people are good and so when you meet
them and they actually are good that
it's like I believe in humanity what a
crush the net don't meet your idols
thing your heroes they want to crush
that and if I'm ever anyone's here on
they me I want to be like oh that's a
fun mission statement yo who was who is
have you ever like fanboy over someone
oh yeah yeah yeah
like who I was a fan of you two before I
got into it so like every youtuber I
mean even still now if it's like someone
who is somewhat of a peer but still
bigger and I haven't met them yet I
still get excited because like you're
meeting someone who's doing something
awesome it's like that excites me so
like who did I fan over or is there
someone you haven't met yet that you
know that you would totally yeah oh I
remember one so Kyle Mooney oh yeah he's
great we went
- Nick do you know Nick by chance yeah
yeah yeah we went - I think it was
Nick's birthday party and Kyle was there
and we knew his gonna be there yeah so
just like having conversations yeah I
didn't even say like I'm a big fan I was
just like just conversing in whatever
way worked but in my head I'm like so
like low-key and chillin like a crazy
character that exactly you almost I've
been in social situations with him like
a couple times and I'm usually way more
drunk than he is in this situation and I
have to remind myself that like usually
sure I'm being a little aggressive right
now I got crazy but then some of me like
I feel like that cuz we always used to
be a lot and we still are a lot but like
we used to be way more hyper around
people - whether it's be uncomfortable
and that's how we feel we can get people
to like us yeah I don't know never
really dived into it Dovan to it but uh
yeah I think that we've like chilled out
more but even then I still think about
it and I'm like do it can I just be me
like should I just be me and be hyper
and enjoy myself or do I need to like
suppress my craziness for them yeah who
I want to like me but so like you think
about that you're like I don't know over
the place in my head about all of this
right I [ __ ] you up now from this
you're like what's your improv
background zero joseline zero yeah I
haven't taken any classes yeah the only
I just have a music background from like
I took guitar lessons for two months and
then I already knew how to play
everything so they were just teaching me
songs I didn't know I just kind of could
do things okay I just enjoyed doing it
and if you enjoy doing it you'll do it
so much more than the average person and
then you can end up getting good at
something you know so yeah what's
speaking music what's like a sugar pine
song that gets stuck in your head the
most hmm if there is one how many how
many have you guys made so far I think
six or seven yeah and we have one coming
up pretty soon but I think they it
periodically gets stuck on my head like
right now my type is like manna
I think Steve's just like a maniac with
creating these like melodies and
instrumentals but I
it'll get stuck in my head as we're
making it and for a month after yeah and
then it's just that the latest song will
be stuck on my head I think yeah yeah
yeah do you guys have been doing live
shows right yeah we'll be doing our
second one pretty soon oh cool and the
first one went great
yes awesome yes it was so much fun we
were really nervous yeah we just went
out there filmed it and we plan to do
the same you know what's the format of
it we're working on it but the first one
format wise was to just go out and kind
of have it be less plan like that was
kind of our stick but that's also like
an excuse to to not network yeah but
like people like to kind of expect that
from us to like we're kind of a mess you
know they don't want to see a polished
show exactly we're trying to polish this
one but in general we're gonna go out
there and bit a little bit and I mean
like as if it's like a kind of like a
play in the beginning for the first five
minutes a little roll into a music video
and then come out and introduce
everybody and then just kind of talk and
goof and gaff and do music in between
you know cuz how big is the quote like
cast right now um there's four five six
seven I think oh wow yeah and have you
all been cast in this or is this like
friends joining in the live shows yeah
you mean the show in general no I think
I think technically like that we
consider like our editors part of the
show too cuz like they're in the show
they're like our best friends at the
office and everything so technically the
editors got casted like we hired Ottoman
originally like she's not with us
anymore but originally she was we hired
her to edit for the show so that's kinda
like bringing on same with the Vicki she
was hired on but it really just I guess
James dawn McCune he was in Blair at the
Blair Witch the newer one so we found
out that he knew of us somehow or
something and we were just like amazed
by that and then we're like I'll come on
the show yeah it's just like a guest
character and then we had him on more
frequently more frequently so no one was
really cast it just kind of became yeah
exactly are you what are the upcoming
plans are you guys adding more people
um we're not really planning to add more
people other than like guests and stuff
like that like I would love to
collaborate with new people because
they're not used to us and it's so fun
to like be crazy around people who don't
like they're not ready for it oh yeah
the first time I was around all of you
guys I was just saying whoa what is
going I left
tired see these bags I leave tired every
day no I can't believe you guys have
such stamina for it then I'm like I
can't keep up I can't it's crazy but
who's this dream guess that you guys
haven't had on you dream guest we
probably all have different ones but
right now I know we're trying to have
Dillon Francis really funny on Twitter
yeah he's super funny right Diane
introduced me to him and he's he does
bits all the time I had no idea yeah so
he like follow Steve and Steve tweeted
Adam saying like hey will you DJ my
wedding and be on our podcast he's like
how about both and so we're like let's
get him on there exactly wait when is
Steve's wedding I have no idea it's
gonna be the summer though do you have
plans of what your are you guys best man
I imagine James and I'll be best man I
think as we talked about but Steve also
asked me hey Steve also asked me to be
his best man in a really nice sweet
moment getting sushi one time and then
he told me Brett was gonna be as from
couch shop was gonna be his best man and
I hurt my feelings and then now to not
hurt anyone's feelings he's gonna make
both James and I as best man I think
we're gonna follow this and see where it
goes okay
what um what is your plan as a best man
hmm I mean it's really far in the future
I don't even know what do you like what
a best men do I've never been a best man
before they like get the groom drunk but
like no you drunk before for the wedding
yeah drunk drunk yeah good for you well
now you're supposed to have time to make
up for it with Steve's yeah that's true
I'm gonna get drunk for his wedding
jaqen for two weddings
are you gonna give a speech I think if
the opportunity arises arose mm-hmm for
sure you can do whatever you want I've
never been a groomsman before I have to
talk to Elissa about it because she's
like a thing it is her day yeah so but I
think you guys should at least do some
sort of choreographed dance Oh totally
yeah oh man yeah do something like you
know those [ __ ] wedding videos where
they like all walk up to like yeah I'm
non-traditional song everyone's going up
do something like that
just some Snoop Dogg's song oh please
okay we're take one more quick break and
we get back we have a bunch of Twitter
questions for you so we write back with
[Music]
support for today's show comes from
bareMinerals creators of clean beauty
purity in formulation and uncompromising
performance have always been the guiding
principles of bare minerals because they
believe that makeup and skin care should
make your skin better not just better
looking this has been the bareMinerals
philosophy since they began the clean
beauty revolution in 1995 with their
best-selling original foundation which
offers creamy lightweight buildable
coverage that's naturally luminous the
clean formula is made with only 5 good
for skin ingredients all minerals
including non-chemical SPF protection
makeup so pure you can sleep in it and
it actually improves your skin over time
it's everything your skin needs and
nothing it doesn't for bare minerals to
be clean without compromise means good
for skin formulas with proven
performance like every bare minerals
product it's 100% cruelty free
better yet both the original and that
loose powder foundations are available
in 30 shades upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match
first time customers will get 15% off
when you use the promo code not too deep
that's bare minerals calm promo code not
too deep for 15% off your first purchase
bare minerals the power of good this
episode of not too deep is Burt
you buy the OkCupid dating app OkCupid
is the only dating app that finds you
someone based on who you are and what
you're into the OkCupid dating app su
fun and meaningful questions that matter
to you so you can be seen by the people
who are going to be into you from
questions like would you pay an extra
five dollars for guac to are you close
to your family or did you vote in the
last election you'll see tons of answers
that lead to great conversations and
great dates with people who feel the
same way that you do tell people about
your favorite album your last great trip
your favorite podcasts and let the love
roll in on OKCupid dating app whether
you're looking for that person to join
you on a long walk on a beach or a short
walk to the pool bar my preferred type
of walk they are waiting for you on the
OkCupid dating app be yourself and enjoy
all the awesome people like you who want
to meet you on the OkCupid dating app
download the free OkCupid dating app to
find your next great date today okay
okay before we get into the Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions ask every guest that's on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most throw want to throw
cold spaghetti at cold spaghetti oh yeah
umm [ __ ] I want to throw cold
spaghetti a Hitler there you go it's
called spaghetti [ __ ] yeah yeah okay
and the other question is - tell us your
worst pants [ __ ] story or close call
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so mine is college
jogging front lawn
oh yeah is very descriptive even though
there's only three words don't like a
timer can I think about it give me a
close call situation - it can be oh I
remember
okay laughing shorts ball
okay well no follow-up questions there
is it understandable oh I can are we
talking about a sports ball no ball of
laughing shorts young enough for that to
be okay no it was embarrassing okay
let's give into these Twitter questions
someone says I love beyond the pine and
sometimes you guys talk about films on
there and I love listening because I
also love films you guys inspired me to
start creating would you guys ever
consider a separate channel to review
films in depth or just stick it to the
podcast um I don't think we'd make a
second channel for like a podcast film
thing we did talk about that a little
while ago and I was like you know with
YouTube's algorithms I think they're
favoring like new channels that have
instantly a lot of views and if we
brought views over to a new channel
maybe it would get pushed in the
algorithm and was like yeah I think
we're just trying to make this channel
work first you know but um yeah guess
that's all we almost made another show
for it yeah do any of you guys make
content on your individual channels yeah
I make I like recently I'm on like the
fifth episode but I have a podcast now
called Grand Master pod cool and it's
like it's just about whatever it's a
solo podcast I just like a crazy person
yeah I sit in my house and I have a
ficus to the right of me drink cold brew
and I just talk about anything that
comes to me mm-hmm yep stories what I'm
doing funny things yeah if there's
something funny to talk about I'll talk
about it or something that's just like
if I see a video a viral video from ten
years ago I just talk about it and like
show it and laugh about it does it makes
me remember my life more cuz I was
terrible like I'm very in the moment and
I enjoy the moments like I'm thoroughly
enjoying this and I'll remember that I
was on your podcast yeah like just every
moment I just try to enjoy it in the
moment then I also forget it
same in the same way that I'm like ah as
my brain just bad it's the same but it
helps me weekly try to remember what
that I do this week yeah and then I'll
talk about it a little bit like the
Comedy Store stuff
to the comedy store like such an amazing
time but I would forget it and never
think about it again for three years
unless I decided to talk about it and
what I did I'm go through it and that's
like it's therapeutic in that sense for
me to remember my life and appreciate it
do you do stand-up I'm trying to my
Falzone has been like a mentor get off
now we can bring Mike he's amazing he
like brought me to the comedy store the
day after I went with Steve and
introduced me to everybody there and you
know like I already know so much about
it cuz I've been a fan of it forever but
it's one of those things that I'm
terrified to do I don't know if I can
write good jokes don't know if I can
perform them well right it's like a math
equation that you're figuring out for
yeah exactly like Joe could be good but
your delivery could come off bad and it
doesn't works you there's so much to
figure out and but you haven't done it
yet I haven't done it yet and I
desperately want to but I'm just do I
taking the steps I'm learning about it
I'm going I'm hanging out and yeah I'm
trying to write [ __ ] I saw Mike do
stand-up for the first time a couple
weeks ago and he's so funny so good I
think he told one joke and then just in
crowd were just like [ __ ] with the
audience and he doesn't piss people off
or something you told me was like you
know a lot of people think that crowd
work is like making fun of the crowd but
it doesn't have to be like that and once
the crowd realizes that you're not
making fun of them by doing crowd work
you're just like nothing with them right
they're way more open to it yeah he's
got a great great bit of being able to
like self reflect and like something
deprecated and then balanced way so the
crowds like okay we're on your side yeah
I'm supposed to know who has the
gnarliest Bape tricks oh I had the
gnarliest wave trick you guys are all I
don't vape anymore you didn't quit I
quit a while ago and then I couldn't
really quit and like I quit in for a
month I quit and then I would still do
it randomly in the office because
everyone's [ __ ] vaping around me
which is like it's my own thing I know
that I'm taking responsibility but it
made me want it more than if it just
wasn't around me I'm so much more easily
accessible you know so I was still
vaping and then the diction was still
there and I quit and I think I'm like
five days
without any nicotine whatsoever it's
hard but it's so you just went cold
turkey yeah cold turkey
you know the wife doesn't love it
doesn't like it and yeah she shouldn't
of course you shouldn't and it's amazing
but it's just tough I'm just I don't
want to be someone who is addicted to
anything because something that made me
it like resonated with me which is
something I only said to myself but it
was that the amount of time when you're
addicted to something that you think
even subconsciously instead of a being
all day and the time you are doing it
you could be using that time anywhere
else more productively you know it's
just a waste of time and it just it
doesn't help me didn't make me funnier
it didn't make me grow as a person
only took away from productivity that's
a very mature thought process to have
about it but Steve not gonna quit I
don't think he's gonna quit
I don't think Jim's gonna quit either
all accidentally got added well I like
did it on purpose I liked it and then I
chose to start because I was vaping no
nicotine when I first started with John
I was for fun and then I was like no I
want to feel the nicotine Rasha like
that yeah and then you get addicted to
it and then they started doing it they
got accidentally addicted to it by
hitting mine now and again and got their
own vibes man now it's just a sad thing
and then but there's a silver lining you
can quit if you want to it's true and
you're doing it yeah they won't quit
until something really bad happens
somebody said it seems like when I find
out my health is like in rough shape I'm
fully in jeopardy
then he'll quit and power James too and
you know that's those bridges and
avoiding it yes women through the water
someone says big or small dogs small
dogs well I like the big dogs better but
I get ripped apart for it and you know
what it's too [ __ ] bad everybody I
understand but I'm gonna get a Frenchie
and you know what I talked to people are
like you need to adopt and I fully
support that and I think in general you
should but like this dog fits my
lifestyle I want it to be healthy you
know and and someone at the because you
know people say like you shouldn't get
those breeders and supports
I understand it but the breeders at this
show we went to said you know what like
what we say when people say that to us
as breeders is that we're breeding these
dogs because they're gonna exist anyways
we're breeding them super healthy and a
human in a humane way and giving them to
them just give them to anybody they give
them a great home so the breed exists
and they're doing the best they can
top tier with the help the health of the
dog and the home it goes to and I think
that there is like it's it's exist so
I'm gonna give it an amazing home and
that's that dog is gonna exist whether I
get it or not and I want to give it the
best life it's got so let's see I'm
sorry for those people who are against
it I'm obsessed with French bulldogs I
follow so many of them on and Frenchy
have you followed that one
no but I've Frank the funny Frenchy
Charles Barkley oh yeah or Sir Charles
Barkley I forget Rene Charles James
chose Buckley yeah I've got to a point
where I had to like go through and like
unfollow because it was really yeah and
I don't have a French Bulldog so I have
a different dog it's starting to be
offensive to the dog yeah exactly is
there plans in the works for also yes
you were at a French Bulldog show yeah
well it was just a dog show but there
was a an hour where they were showing
French bulldogs and we went because
we've been researching him for like a
year and found it that like you don't
get a French Bulldog from a breeder
who's got an Instagram page or even has
a website the people you get a breeder
from of these people that don't have
breeds often they're not doing it for
money they just have really healthy dogs
and they're keeping that lion alive and
they do it every couple of years and you
get one from a breeder like that who has
like healthy good dogs and doesn't give
them to anybody you know and you have to
like find your research yeah yeah you
can even find them online like you have
to like go meet them at like a dog show
so that's what I know right now
so when are you acquiring said Frenchie
the latest I would say is Christmas this
Christmas because that's when there's
time off to spend time with do you have
a name in it we do yeah it actually
already has an Instagram we don't even
have it two days ago
Odie but spell OT like Oh ATI II mean
like oatmeal OD meal OD the Frenchie
that
very cute okay I will go follow and just
wait you don't need to don't go follow
it right now or on there yeah exactly
yeah it's actually the picture is of a
like an achievement not unlocked yet so
it's the dog but it's a silhouette of
the dog and you can't see it opened it
yet we haven't gotten the gene
someone says pros and cons of your new
Miata oh you know I have oh I thought
you knew ahead of me out of here so I
was like you know I love my car pros and
cons pros everything it's awesome it's
great it's I get to be with the top down
when you're in LA like I need the Sun
yeah Jules me if I'm in the dark chillin
I get depressed and so so many pros it's
fun it's parkings easy yeah you get the
Sun it's a pretty good on gas cons I'm
over 6 foot dude oh yeah that is [ __ ]
small so if [ __ ] sucks sometimes and
you're stuck in traffic for that long
are you driving to San Diego yeah
it's comfortable but not that
comfortable for someone of my size how
long it's gonna meddle gray and has got
a rims with a cherry red soft top wow I
thought so too
you didn't just want to get like a hot
red one that's like a black top to look
like I had a way better car than it
really was not that expensive really
it's just cool there's no worst hair
choice they've made in their past they
wish they could undo like my words hair
choice
I mean you know it's it's hard to say
that I want to take something back
because it led you to where you weren't
now you sure I used to have the long
long long long Beiber flow but maybe
choice of color one time in like the
eighth grade I dyed my hair black but
did it from home with my mom who's not a
hairdresser and then it turned gray I
had I was the youngest old man with
Bieber hair to ever exist that's amazing
it was at first it was like black for
one day and I was like oh yeah I'm
[ __ ] I'm so even a so goth and emo or
whatever yeah and then it just went
green and like sort of like a greenish
bluish green and then gray I was great
for so long
for how long weeks weeks and weeks and
weeks mom pranked you yeah so hard yeah
and I gotta get her back
what's the best inspiration when it
comes to bits or music or anything
really
everyone's inspirations different yeah
like for me with music what inspires me
to like write and just get into it is
watching live performances of the bands
that I like watching interviews and
hearing them talk and and that just like
fires me the [ __ ] up yeah I just can
jump right into it especially with a
coffee to like caffeine I'm inspired
with comedy stand-up has been a big like
watching stand-up of people I really
like broadcast from comedians that I
really like yeah what are you so - um I
love Tiger belly I love yo Vaughn yeah
it's Bobby Lee and kalila that man is
just like funny to his course so
funniest podcast is amazing he's got
great people on it so like Tiger belly
theof on Joe Rogan now and again but
he's a little boring and and Chris
D'Elia his Larry I've been listening to
his stuff for years he's he's like she's
just so funny yeah he's like confidently
funny and not many people can pull that
off ago looking like a dick totally I
mean yeah he Anthony Jeselnik
I feel like have similar energy that way
I ever heard of Anthony Jeselnik
Jeselnik if you want to see someone into
amazing crowd work he is like a [ __ ]
shark I'm sure he's heard that before a
hundred million times I'm supposed to
know how far does a bit go before
someone breaks you guys ever get mad at
each other for breaking no never
breaking is like if you can make your
friend break after making trying to make
them laugh every single day for two
years yeah and you won then that's a
good bet yeah I actually want to leave
more breaking in the actual videos
because we don't but break it's my
favorite thing to make them break it's
also just such a good it's it's like
verbal consent what you're doing is good
exactly and then also I think it's like
a verbal cue for people watching it
laugh track the whole reason there's a
live track but this it's like genuine -
so brakes the most out of you guys I
think James probably brakes oh really
James and then Steve and then me Oh
interesting James I would peg as someone
that was more stoic and that's his
character but he is his stoic but he
loves to laugh yeah and he gets the
humor and so making him he just like
he'll if something's funny he'll just
laugh yeah burst out laughing
that's great yeah someone says can we
expect another big project soon like the
woods I would love to see more short
films and such from y'all actually I we
were pleasantly surprised but we were
good we were encouraged to start when we
have free time to work on another short
film so it's just finding the time and
with the grind which is the lamest thing
in the world but does sometimes feel
like a grind you know we were to do the
greatest thing in the [ __ ] world and
how dare I
you know it's literally you guys are
grinding you're working 9:00 to 5:00
that's fine but like it still it takes a
toll creatively because you use all your
creative juices then you have none left
for your side project your side place
your side Howe would you make for that
sweet side honey
would um would the short be you guys as
your characters they want to challenge
yourselves well I'm so like when we did
the woods and that was fun but we're
still like tone down versions of
ourselves
sure and funny enough I actually wasn't
supposed to be called kid but I was we
decided was gonna be clay but then
someone forgot to change kid in the
script to clay last minute so everyone
script just said kid but yeah we want to
try to do something something different
comedy this time though because I feel
like when you are known for something
you should have for your first few
projects anyways you just should have an
essence of what people already like you
for totally it's more approachable for
your audience and you don't want to get
let down and then assume that everything
moving forward is gonna be exactly
someone to know are you gonna release
any solo music yeah I've been saying
that I'm gonna for the longest time and
yes I am going to I just need time I
need time and the motivation but I
absolutely well in the next course I
definitely will myself this year's gonna
very exciting today do you hear that
someone let's know what are you glad you
changed about yourself since starting SP
seven I've become more confident myself
and I've like found myself more I'm
still finding myself but yeah SP seven
has really helped me just like grow a
person and become the person I want to
be um but also like there's negatives to
with like you know doing things but I
found the things that I like about
myself and I found the things I don't
like about myself in my selves there's
multiple of me yeah and I want to just
like work on the things I like and try
to eliminate some of the things I don't
like and I'm sure that will benefit
myself in the future
yeah what's coming up in the future for
you guys we want to hopefully just like
revitalize our show to a more stable
place so that we have more leniency with
time to do other projects but music is
our big thing right now where we're like
really excited about it we're enjoying
what we're making the audience seems to
really like it and there could be like a
tour in the future asking about like
you've done a show in LA where are you
gonna go with it yeah we we talked about
possibly filming us go on to her I don't
want to go too much into it would that
be fun without asking if I'm allowed to
which she knows but yeah like if the
show revolves around that and then we're
on tour you know like you're really fun
I think it'd be awesome I'd love to see
just be a change up from the old office
yeah then it gets your creative juices
flowing again totally location can
change everything if you just go
somewhere else for one day just changes
everything 100% clay we've reached the
end of the podcast thank you so much for
being here for giving us your time you
get a gift that everyone gets a [ __ ]
sized fortune cookie as part of our
hospitality
that's so sweet show me to break it sure
I don't even know what's in this yeah
that's very humble all right let's see
what it says let's see it's a surprise
for all of us Wow
very long oh okay on November 14th 2018
12:15 p.m. PST you promised Twitter 10k
retweets and I'll grow this mustache out
again do you understand good
let this be a PSA to everyone listening
to find out this tweet and retweet thank
you god damn it right now it's only a
couple thousand I think okay well if we
can get at the ten thousand you have to
regrow a mustache I will there you go if
that's if that happens I will very cool
some of me is excited for that and some
is not excited to have my wife look at
me like this my sisters are very end
maybe she has changed her mind maybe
it'll grow better it once was well where
can people find you and sb7 if they
don't know you can find me at
youtube.com slash sugar pine 7-4 sugar
pine seven that's the group of us you
can find me personally at youtube.com
slash CIB and that's where I do my
podcast and do funny little sketches and
then we're on social media by the same
name sir combined seven and official sb7
and not Kip on twitter yeah literally at
not cut not Kip yeah thank you so much
thank you for having it go check them
out if you have it already and I'll see
you next time another episode I'm not
your deep goodbye to deep toady Cody
this episode mention deep is brought to
you by bare minerals as the creators of
clean Beauty bare minerals is driven by
the philosophy that makeup and skincare
should make your skin better not just
better looking that's why their
best-selling original foundation is made
with only five ingredients all minerals
for bare minerals to be clean without
compromise means good for skin formulas
with proven performance upgrade to clean
beauty products use the foundation
finder at bare minerals calm to find
your perfect match
first time customers will get 15% off
when you use the promo code not too deep
bare minerals the power of good not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]